- Coy Nolin fait partie
des anciens élèves qui accusent
les responsables de l'école
et de l'église Mile Two Church
de maltraitance criminelle
survenue entre 1995 et 2010.
Il rapporte avoir été victime
de maltraitance 0000004,
alors que quatre visiteurs
auraient placé leurs mains
sur lui, marmonnant des prières
pendant près d'une heure
et procédaààà un exorcisme pour
le guérir de ce qu'ils disaient
être des démons homosexuels.
Dans une réfutation écrite
des allégations, la direction
'é'é'école affirme :
L'établissement ajoute aussi
avoir procédé à des changements
de personnel et de politique,
affirmant que les étudiants
LGBTQ+ sont les bienvenus.
Insultes, châtiments physiques
et isolement cellulaire sont
des exemples de maltraitance
rapportés par d'autres anciens
étudiants de l'école.
Après 12 md'd'd'enquête,
le Service de police de
Saskatoon a transféré le dossier
au procureur de la Couronne
en avrilnininier. Une décision
concernant le statut de
la plainte collective est
attendue d'ici avril 2023.
v v victimes rapportent
que la majorité des événements
ont eu lieu après la décision
de la Cour suprême du Canada,ent
illégal d'imposer des châtiments
corporels à des enfants.
Les anciens élèévévévoquent
aussi le manuel disciplinaire
"The Child-Training Seminar",
vendu aux côtés de bibles
et de palettes de bois
dans la boutique de cadeaux.
"CBC/Radio-Canada a obtenu
une copie du document de
85 pages, qui contient
huit leçons indiquant de
ne pas laisser les larmes et
les prières atténuer la sévérité
de la punition.
Cependant, rien n'indique
que le manuel circule encore ou
que ses méthodes sont utilisées
par le personnel.
Les anciens élèves demandent au
gouvernement de la Saskatchewan
de cesser le financement
de l'école jusqu'à ce que
l'enquête soit terminée.
De son côté, le ministère de
l'Éducation de la Saskatchewan
a affirmé que les écoles
indépendantes étaient évaluées
trois fois par année, dont
la dernière datait du 8 juin.
Le Ministère a également ajouté
qu'aucune plainte n'avait été
reçue contre cette école depuis
que les subventions accordées
aux écoles indépendantes
qualifiées ont commencé,
en 2012.
Ici Kassandra Leb
Radio-Canada, Regin